questions from Brian and Tennessee Dave
I'm working on my debt snowball
I have everything listed from the
smallest debt to the largest my largest
debt is my student loan of 74 thousand
it is currently listed last currently by
the way student loan is itemized there
are amounts that are smaller than some
of the other credit card debts that I
have should I pay the student loan off
as a line item or treat the student loan
as a big total sum you don't do your
debt snowball by category you do it by
loans and so if your student loans are
broken up into 20 to $4,000 loans then
you list them out as 20 to $4,000 loans
you don't list them by category in other
words if you had two car payments twenty
thousand and ten thousand you enlisted
as a thirty thousand dollar debt you
have a ten thousand dollar car and a
$20,000 car and so you break it out by
the actual loans not by the category the
reason for this is real simple personal
finances eighty percent behavior it's
only 20 percent of head knowledge so we
have to manage behaviors if you were man
if you weren't managing behaviors I mean
if you're managing behaviors you
wouldn't gone into credit card debt
because no one consciously sits around
and goes hey I think you'd be really
smart to be 28 percent in debt paying
28% interest to buy an ice-cream cone
you know but stupid but we do that stuff
all the time right and so but you don't
you're not doing that with like math
skills you're doing that because your
behaviors are out of control and so you
fix it with a behavior fix not a
behavior or not a math fix so you want
to see the progress no sane human being
will keep doing something which they can
see absolutely no progress on if you go
to the Y and you work out five hour
and you quit eating any food and you
don't lose any weight you will go back
to eating food and sitting on the couch
you have to see progress for your pain
or you won't keep engaging in the pain
you have to live like no one else so
that later you can live and give like no
one else that's what this is about
so all that to say is I want you to pay
off the smallest student loan because I
want you to draw red lines through this
and keep the gift of that snowball on
the refrigerator and should see all
those red lines all those all the
progress you've made how you've moved
the needle on this it's a big difference
it makes a difference